no bad David
me here why would you bet on Goliath
when we got bit David now you taming
giving values contagious this world of
entrepreneurs we get no value to haters
[Music]
completely everyone I'm in La okay yeah
like an hour so listen today we have a
special podcast let me explain to you
why this is special
uh with all the tragic events taking
place in Iran and the courageous
protests are going on around the world
specifically in Iran women leading the
way with the youth we decided to do
special podcasts to just discuss the
topic of Iran and we got
four special guests here with us one of
them this is our Assyrian atom we call
them Vinnie oshana
who's here with us second we have
nazanin Noor who made some strong
comments about New York Times I want to
say last week that went viral everybody
was talking about it everybody was
sending it to us if you don't know who
she is her background she's appeared on
Prime TV us shows like Madam Secretary
Criminal Minds political Minds she's
also the creative mind behind Persian
mom and many other things on top of that
she graduated from George Mason
University with a degree in government
and international politics her double
major is in communication but I love her
minor yeah her minor is in media
criticism how awesome is that minor
right which is appropriate for New York
Times I like it what criticize a lot of
things that's good we're going to do a
lot more of it today hopefully
and then we have morteza alborzi okay
former world champion 12 uh consecutive
Iran national champion head coach for
Iran and U.S national karate team and
over 17 000 students of which over 1200
black belts he was a former political
prisoner an activist 24 7 the last 43
years and uh his uh obsession is to make
sure he brings Freedom back to Iran so
we can go back to Iran one day and
celebrate uh the rich history that Iran
has and you see him right there on the
cover of the Masters uh magazine martial
arts I think you're a ninth degree black
belt if I'm not mistaken so much thank
you he should be my hand in the green
room and almost my Knuckles broke I told
you don't do it I don't know make you
angry it hurts so bad well the whole
thing is we're safe that's the most
important he's on our side and then last
but not least there's only one way to
introduce the last person that we have
here and it's a picture can we just show
one picture so this will all explain oh
my God the last person is so the guy to
the right is a guy named Patrick David
okay and the guy to the left is my
sister Paulette Davis who's also here
with us and the reason why I wanted to
also bring my sister Paulette is because
she's got not only strong opinions but
she's got a different perspective
because she lived in Iran up until uh 16
years old and she was probably old
enough to remember the revolution taking
place so you probably have some history
there memories there Paula to share with
everybody else and that picture does it
I mean that picture should pretty much
tell you how this whole thing got
started with that hijab look at how
she's wearing that hijab because not
because of choice but because of force
because it's what's normal in the
country that we were born and raised in
so having said that uh we want to
welcome everybody here on the podcast so
good to have you guys on thank you very
much and as usual we have Tyler here as
well Tyler is not Iranian but he's got
the beard of an Iranian so we're going
to make it work okay all right so let's
get right into so nazanin uh uh uh
morteza Paulette we'll start with you
guys first
um when you first heard the news of
what's going on with this you got really
passionate you've been passionate about
this for a minute here obviously your
degree even says what your passion's
been around this for while
what happened with this one where you
suddenly went out there you gave your
rant with New York Times and now
everybody is curious to know where
they're saying well this doesn't make
any sense they're saying it's economical
they're not saying it's because of women
they're not saying because of that give
us your thoughts on what's going on with
Iran and how you all of a sudden wanted
to voice your opinion about this well I
think I've voiced my opinion on Iran for
many years but I feel like I've held
back like many people in the diaspora do
for many different reasons for those
that don't know some people fear
persecution even that's how far the
Islamic Republic has its reach because
it instills fear even in people that
don't live there and especially if you
have family and friends there and then
this specific case I feel like for
massagina amini it was the same thing
that got Iranians out in the streets it
was like the straw that broke the
camel's back it was like really
again and this violently
um and then the New York Times thing was
I read the article first of all the
headline was very misleading
um and what was the body of the article
of course there's things in there that
are factual it's correct of course the
economy is bad uh but the economy isn't
bad just because of what's going on
right now it's been in a steep decline
for like a couple decades so there's a
lot of things at play and again I'm not
an economic expert so I can't really
speak to that but that's not
the whole story so many journalist
friends of mine reached out to me
privately and then some of them went
public too which to me I thought was
interesting I was like okay so it's not
just me that is getting really upset
about this people are looking at this
that are in that profession and saying
well the headline was misleading if you
read parts of the article it makes it
seem like Iran has some sort of
functioning democracy and that there's
these legitimate elections which there
is not and
um I I couldn't fathom how you could see
all of the footage coming out of Iran
and then go write an entire piece that
it's in a well-respected in many circles
publication that's supposed to inform
the masses and so a lot of people are
getting their information and knowledge
from this and if they read this they'll
they will walk away thinking oh yeah
it's the economy not that people don't
want to live under a theocracy not that
people are screaming zanzan degi Azadi
which is woman life Freedom that they
want women want you know bodily autonomy
and human rights they don't want to live
under a theocracy they're literally
screaming death to the dictator death to
the regime and all of those things got
the equivalent of one little sound bite
and like I would say 50 to 60 of the
article focused on well they're out
because of the economy and let's speak
to so and so who owns this Bazaar here
which again very valid but that's not
what pushed people out into the streets
yeah I want to read this so for some of
you that maybe haven't read this article
what what page is it on Tyler if you can
tell me what page it is so I can go
right to it okay so let me read this
article I'm not going to read the whole
thing but I think couple of the
Snippets out of it so you can kind of uh
follow what story she's talking about I
got eight here
I'm on Eighth and I don't see it tell me
what page is it on it's one of the pages
that we had earlier
this is the one you handed oh no six
page six right at the top Out Of Reach
dreams in a sickly economy
okay so this is New York Times October
2nd Out Of Reach dreams in a sickly
economy provoked A Rage in Iran right
when Nader a 41 year old Construction
Company employee in Tehran shops for
groceries he constantly adjusts his list
as he wanders the aisles double checking
prices and factoring them into his
budget his basket keeps shrinking as
inflation surges a year ago he gave up
red meat and chicken now with Nader's
savings gone and his rant having doubled
even cheese and eggs are becoming
luxuries I can't keep up with the rising
prices no matter how hard I run
um you know as a taxi driver to afford
clothes the school books for his son and
a telephone interview our demand is for
the government to fix the economy to
understand that we are breaking under
Financial pressure Nader like tens of
thousands of Iranians taking part in a
nationwide protest against the
government in the past two weeks has
plenty of grievances to choose from
soaring prices high unemployment
corruption political repression and the
law required women to dress modestly
modestly and cover their hair that last
issue set off unrest when a young woman
Masa amini died two weeks ago in the
custody of the morality police but the
story state of Iran's economy is one of
the main four susparent Iranians into
streets to demand chain so you you read
something like this
you know and it's not like it's a small
newspaper this is New York Times now
um a lot of people have lost a lot of
trust for New York Times on you know
posing sides you know whatever the out
there even Bill Mars not talking uh
highly about New York Times City that he
did before uh morteza when you read
something like this and you see with
what's going on with an in America a lot
of people are going to read the saying
oh all these videos are just videos it's
not really that bad it's just another
country in the Middle East that they're
protesting that goes on all the time
it's fine let's not pay attention to it
let's pay attention to other things why
is this so important for people that are
not Iranian to pay attention to
uh look practitioner as I mentioned most
of my uh stories on Instagram Facebook
this is not happening because of what
happened to Masa this was a bomb vading
waiting 43 years for a country that was
second in gas third in oil
15 precious medals fifth in Gold uh
fifth strongest army in the world
with a passport that 157 doesn't need a
visa to go to 157 countries
pre-revolution you're talking about 77
76 exactly right and on 77 and 78 was
the second not third second most visitor
tourists that visit our country turning
to the point that now people finding
food in the trash can I get emotional I
talk about it even
that country which provided so many
Geniuses 5500 professor in United States
universities
Iranian wow one-third of NASA are
Iranian now the uh Sharif University is
getting surrounded by police and we know
what's going to happen to those kids we
know what's going to happen today when
you say we know yeah because just assume
people don't know what will happen to
those kids what exactly happened to two
events before that what happened you
think right now 185 87 or 89 people got
killed no asking me three four thousand
people got killed because all those
people that got arrested
there is no sign and like last time they
find the body of 2100 of them
it's not just that people got killed in
the street
I got a picture this morning from the
doctor we have a medical clinic
underground where it's uh basically in
Tehran yeah in Tehran we're helping them
with the money that these doctors
serving people that they got shot and so
on so because if they step in a hospital
immediately they get arrested they're
not even letting go in the doctor post a
picture said
by the law you cannot come to hospital
and shot at the injured
and he put a picture on it that they
went to the hospital and do it now
imagine what they're going to do when
they take you to the custody on jail may
I say something about that because I got
messages from inside of Iran about the
hospital situation somebody a couple
people told me oh my so and so is the
chief at this hospital and at this
hospital and they were warning patients
not to use their real names because if
you come in with any type of wound that
shows that you were maybe in a protest
or hit a protest you could get arrested
and he's talking about shotif University
that just happened a few days ago for
your listeners um where they this is
it's like the Harvard the MIT in Iran
you have the best and brightest students
there and they just surrounded it the
government forces and chased them out
they got blocked into the garage some
people made it out some people got
arrested beaten they're in a lot of
students are still in jail which is why
a lot of students are protesting at
universities right now asking for their
friends and their classmates to be
released
I mean that's pretty wild when you say
that to a regular person they're like
what are you talking about that's really
the life right now in Iran and New York
Times is saying you know it's a fair
election you know racy that he had last
year and lowest amount of turnout in
elections since 1979 and you know Stats
come out and hey this was already
predetermined so for for Iran let me
even take a step back you know why does
Iran matter so much to you okay pull it
for you we were born in Iran okay we
lived there for a while but we're not
we're Assyrian we're Armenian we've been
in America for quite some time what's so
special about Iran to you memories you
want to go back and there's so much
history in Iran I remember when the
revolution happened I was actually
researching it and I came across an
article that back in 1979 women
protesting forced hijab so there were
about 100 000 women that were on the
streets fighting that they didn't want
to have hijab right and this is right
after Romanian March said that yeah
job's going to be mandatory it says on
on March 8 1979 more than 100 000 women
gathered on the street to protest hijab
and I remember Mom used to take us to
there was a street called Gandhi it's
still there and they had like the first
malls and everything came there and to
get us um Italian ice cream right and so
we're there and all of a sudden back
then they would call it a seppah it was
sarola they used to call the Sorrows
right and they were in the cars and they
were just chasing to see which
is uh it was a it's like the police of
hijab police of Hedgehog
yeah it's just the same it's the same
thing it's just a different thing this
one make sure the listeners know what
we're talking about okay and then we
were out in this was you were three I
was about nine and Mom we were walking
on the street and then the morality
police charged at Mom and said what are
you doing you're raising a prostitute
her hair is causing a man to sin and so
do you remember this I remember that the
way she was 10 years old and mom was
fighting back don't talk to me like
because just like this mask that became
mandate all of a sudden that's what I
had so many flashbacks when the mask
came back and I'm like you gotta fight
this this is all psychological fight so
anyways
um then after that mom got me the first
through study head job how old I was 10
10 I was nine and a half and was it like
was it something for you palette where
it was like I'm I'm a woman now I'm
wearing a hijab or was it kind of like I
don't want to wear this or was it like
everybody does it so I am doing it as
well do you remember like what it was
free it wasn't none of those it was we
just have to protect ourselves to be
safe
because kids were missing and the the
back then because in 1967 uh Family
Protection Law was reappealed
there was a family protection law that
protected women and they said the um age
of marriage for women went up to 15 then
Shaw and uh their cabinet took it up to
uh
Malik is that from your side or no
because we hear the sound and it's I'm
off I don't have any I'm on airplane
mode
okay can you check to see if your own
phone is off see if yours is a computer
playback I can hear it's playback
yeah
but I don't have anything yeah it's not
me years either mine is off okay keep
going keep going so you were saying so
uh you were explaining the story the age
of marriage went up to 50 15 18 and then
after the revolution they dropped it out
to nine and then they took it up to 13.
so for Mom was we just have to do what
they say because I don't want them to
come and snatch my kid that was the only
reason why
that was the only reason why just to
make sure follow the rules conform so
they leave us alone exactly Conformity
is becoming the norm and the 15 became
13 and in some cases today women in Iran
the whole concept of hijab is that you
become a woman at nine years old and you
hear stories about 52 year old men
marrying a nine-year-old which is some
random stories when you hear that not as
prevalent or common in Iran it isn't if
you know to keep it factual yes it
happens but it happens more do you
realize what you just said how weird
that is to me to even hear to even say
it's not prevalent meaning it doesn't
happen every day I totally understand oh
no but the fact that like I explained my
10 year old son I said okay I want you
to think about what what is okay in Iran
that it happens once in a while he said
what's that I said how old's your sister
six I said can you imagine your
nine-year-old daughter let's just say a
nine-year-old sister Sena becomes nine
she's okay to marry a 52 year old he's
like what are you talking about that
yeah he's a 10 year old kid the the
conditions over there are so but here's
a challenge like you're almost
conditioned to think it's normal how
about to you what does Iran mean to you
because for you if I doing the research
with your family I think your parents
came here 75 I think they went back they
came back if I'm not mistaken I'm trying
to get some of the stories yeah they
came in 75 to go to university and it
was like a lot of Iranians they came to
get a degree and then they were going to
go back to Iran
um but while they were in America the
revolution happened
um again I think important for your
listeners to know that we went from a
monarchy to a theocracy as well in 1979.
um so they were in University the
revolution happened and then it was like
okay well let's see what's gonna happen
after and then the Iran Iraq war started
um and then you know everybody in Iran
all the family was like you guys should
just stay there especially because then
I was born during the iran-iraq war
um and they were like especially with
daughter you guys should just say in
America and that happened to a lot of
families that the plan was to go back
but they just they stayed here so if
Alberti how about yourself
my best memories of my life was from
that country
all the Honors that they brought for the
country that brought the flag for the
country up
and then
when I'm thinking about jail
and even
every second of it I'm thinking about
what is happening to these people
I was seven years prohibited after I
left Evin
uh although I've got 49 times again
arrested from one hour to one one and a
half a year wow I was four times in
front of uh assassination line which
anytime they could make a mistake and
like
shoot me right but what I came out when
I came out
I was like I have one mission in my life
then this fire doesn't gonna go down on
me until I see this regime go down
because I cannot accept prostitution age
in my country comes to the 12th
12 years old 12 years old 12 years old
officially yeah they're getting paid
there are videos about it in my chat
they officially they have office they're
offering to work there 13 years 14 years
you want it for an hour you want it
forever yeah yeah it's like a temporary
marriage so it's like legal in the eyes
of Islam in their eyes of Islam legal in
the eyes of us of their religious
reasons say this is
more Count Of Heaven for you ladies if
you do that with the people they're
coming from Iraq and you know side
countries to here you give them a
pleasure you have more count of Heavens
because they come from Caraballo because
oh like a Holy Land
so she said something she said you know
we went from a monarchy to a theocracy
okay so again everybody's heard the
stories of musadir we know the stories
about you know Muhammad a few people
know about his father how he also was in
Exile and then Khomeini comes in after
being in Exile twice Boom the next thing
you know Shah leaves and Iran changes
but there were a lot of people that were
for the Shah Fallen there were a lot of
people that said Shaw's a bad person you
know you got savak you did this we
should have had mosadir we should have
had this person you know some say Musa
was a CIA plant some say the Shah was
the puppet of the West you hear all of
these things right and even some of the
kids whatever the kids believe in is
whatever their parents told them for the
most part you know if you're a Christian
it's probably because your parents are
Christians if you're Muslim you're a
Muslim if you're you know an LDS
sometimes you're an LDS about 80 percent
of the time we follow are uh our parents
religion and beliefs that they have
except if there's a broken family then
typically you don't want to follow one
of them because one of them left and
you're kind of like screwed I don't want
to follow your whatever it may be right
there's like an animosity towards a
parent
uh how much of what you know we hear uh
on the monarchy side the criticism of
God how much of that criticism was real
how much of that criticism in your
opinion obviously you know there's only
so much context we have on what we're
talking about what is the difference
between a criticism that got under
Shah's regime versus the criticism that
got under the theocracy we've had the
last 43 years I'll go to you first well
I wasn't alive then but from what I know
um you know so I feel like the
experiences here are going to be able to
speak to it better but from of course
what I've researched and I've been to
Iran many times and you know family and
all that kind of stuff speaking to my
family
um the criticism of the Shah was valid
obviously in the sense that it created
enough dis descent in his own country
that people thought they wanted this
revolution
um they didn't want what came some of
them did but after hominy came in
um everyone was like wait what this is
not what you promised us because as they
can attest to there was how many would
send in cassette tapes from his Exile in
France and it was these sermons and he
was he was saying yeah yeah he was the
original going viral it was saying about
how he was gonna you know women were
gonna be equal and everything was going
to be great and we're going to go back
to this type of a country where it's a
little bit more modest we're going to
get the West Out and because people were
fed up with a lot of people were fed up
with the shaw not everybody
um they were for this and then um your
sister brought up a good point the it's
really interesting that in 1979 when
komini came and was and said actually
hijab is going to be mandatory the women
were like whoa that's not what you
promised us so the same women that were
protesting now somebody I heard some at
The Scholar Academy Saint John poor said
the same women that protested in 1979
against the hijab their granddaughters
now are avenging them which is really
it's a really interesting parallel
because they were literally getting beat
up in the streets as well and they all
said afterward we didn't get what we
thought we were gonna get there's
actually a great documentary that if
your listeners want uh if they want to
get more familiar with Iran it came out
on HBO a few days ago or last week it's
called hostages
four part mini documentary series and it
shows you how we got into the hostage
crisis with the shot leaving and Carter
and Khomeini and the aftermath and it's
really really great for people who don't
know that much about Iran's history
fantastic yeah sure what would you say
you know again criticism pre-shah when
Shah was there you know the uh 2500 year
anniversary he spent way too much money
can you pull up uh put the Iran 2500
year anniversary put this big
celebration it was a big deal and it
created so much critic criticism amongst
people saying why would you spend this
much money go actually to the pictures
so people can see what it was like uh
you go to the pictures and show actually
what it was like uh man if you can show
a real good one okay yeah right there a
lot of people participated in a lot of
people around the country that's right
it was a big deal celebrities political
leaders you know so some people saw that
and they said wow look how strong Iran's
becoming but some people saw that in
Iran and people like Khomeini they said
look how rich the Shah has become and he
has all the money and you're poor and
he's taking all the money what if we can
nationalize the oil what if we can do
this what if we can do that what if we
can have free rights what if we can have
free this and people actually started
falling for this so morteza from your
perspective you're living there at that
time the criticism that the Shah got
that led to 99 million people revolting
against him
versus reality compared to what happened
under Khomeini give us the difference
between the two
as a matter of fact practitioner about
this uh
that Year my brother took me to uh
seventh Air Force Base in Shiraz and I
lived there I saw that demonstration you
were there I was next to the street we
were clapping for the whole thing you
have no idea what kind of honor it had
between all these presidents and Kings
invited there to see our Rich culture we
bring it up to the wall that look who we
are we deserve where we are and we
deserve where we want to go
I sort of agree with the nazanin when
she said if the door was a little bit
open Shaw would let people know
all those things that they were
pretending that they want to bring it
they wouldn't fall for it they wouldn't
fall for it I was working from the ninth
grade 10th grade yeah in a bookstore
right in front of the Tehran University
it was a GB bookstore that was belongs
to enter Charlotte de Francine and I was
a archivist I was taking the inventory
in and out and I was behind the black
glass window
and I would see like how students come
in and looking at this side and that
side and passing for example
to each other and they were scared like
if someone see them let them see that
there is nothing in there it's a kid's
book why are you making this guy so big
that people make it that oh so what's
this song it wasn't a big deal we made
it wasn't a big deal it wasn't a bit
what what soak did sovak is just to put
in context book savak was Iran's CIA
at that time that was trained by the CIA
by the way any country have a security
system that's right of course which
country has it right sure for the saving
this uh country right but point is they
were doing stupid things they were doing
like a thing that it wasn't a big deal
at all what I say if cha would let Jose
almier home
get to open the door for everyone nobody
would watch this regime nobody everybody
knows like what's the origin what's the
inside the regime they close that close
that people are like oh it must be a
magic in there then let's go water yeah
we saw him in the moon all of this
you're saying if he would have uh
allowed people the freedom to learn and
have other other ideologies and thoughts
exactly right that he would yeah so he
shouldn't have been afraid of two-day
party like the Communist party that was
coming in or any of those guys and more
important than that Patrick leadership
comes with a responsibility sure if
you're a leader sometimes you have to
say something that maybe 90 don't like
it but six months from now they adore
you for saying that understanding on
your position sure right
when
whole thing was the starting
my expectation from show was as a leader
of the country that we loved what he did
for the country we we love what his
father did for the country put his foot
down and does it say let me step out of
the country see what they're gonna do
and we paid for it 43 years
to become a most dry country most
poorest country I'm saying he shouldn't
have left no he should have left he
should okay okay so let's process that
let's actually go there if he doesn't
leave what happens you think the people
weren't going to go into the palace and
go in there and get them you don't think
that was good they put in the story for
the cinema Rex they did they couldn't
story for the maid you know if they shot
him that they did because they would
find out that what happened it wasn't a
17 000 death it was 173.
they made these stories big and big and
big and because he was not defending he
was just acting very gentle man very
like a like a classy but doesn't but
doesn't that contradict your argument to
say that if you would have let the
two-day party just come in and present
their arguments you know on one end
you're saying he should have let them on
the other end you're saying he was he
wasn't paranoid enough so if he's too
paranoid Hey Hey listen these two gay
guys let's arrest him put him in the
jail on the other side no no he wasn't
too uh you know paranoid enough how many
had more power than it really did he
should have really controlled it more so
it's like a it's almost like a that's a
game a leadership playing game
leadership playing game when pool when
push yeah I don't know about that one
that's that's going to be a tough one
for him to play thoughts no I was gonna
say don't forget also the Americans role
behind the scenes of all this too they
were they were afraid of the spread of
any type of Communism or anything like
that so they had a vested interest in
playing the parts in the leadership when
you say American leaders who are you
referencing anyone is specifically no
the administration when Jimmy Carter
towards the end yeah got it so got it
well I mean you know we're in the US
right now because of Jimmy Carter
there's no Jimmy Carter we'll probably
be still in Iran right now we're getting
pulled from every side yeah our Persian
Gulf is belongs to 90 right it belongs
to China
gas and gold is Russia obviously West
and East are pulling Iran apart and it's
not in their benefit that right not
supporting people
but also Shaw was dealing with his own
Shah was dealing with his own health
also
right his health was deteriorating
towards the end so it was kind of like
the timing of all of it come together
no I was gonna this all reminded me of
this documentary one of the one of the
hostages are you in it yes I was yeah no
no she's like I'm not the director I'm
the producer um so I want to give it a
plug not the producer but he said
something really interesting where he
said uh one of the hostages he had and
he had an Iranian wife that was waiting
for him back in America
um he said that I'm paraphrasing he said
we were not The Losers of the hostage
crisis because we were there for 444
days and it was it was uncomfortable and
it was distressing
um and it was a bad experience but the
real losers of all of this the real
people that suffered were the Iranian
people because they became a
international Pariah and for the last 42
years when this was shot it was 42 years
um they've had to suffer under this
dictatorship under this theocracy which
is what leads us to
massagina amini it wasn't just about her
it was just like what happened two years
ago with George Floyd it wasn't just
about George Floyd it was a bigger issue
of people protesting systemic racism in
police brutality so this is the same
thing she was the representative of the
match that Lit the fight that was a
match yeah and that was it and it's and
if you don't mind Pat so uh I posted a
video from my podcast I got kind of you
know kind of emotional got to where I
was just kind of pointing out like the
feminists in in this country a lot of
them complained when they could
literally do anything that they want and
I said this poor girl her hat was wrong
and they beat her to death in the street
which triggered me to think about more
things about where the modern day
feminists at here all the big voices all
those celebrities that jump on anything
quick that happens only to Americans
from the Amy Schumer solicit Milanos to
Michelle Obama where are you guys at Amy
did say something she said something she
said something just one one thing it was
one thing and and I totally agree with
yeah by the way we we're all you know
I'm I'm very left I'm a Democrat so I'm
extremely extremely disappointed and
distressed with the response from what I
guess I would say my party in leadership
and you're waiting and I'm thankful that
AOC came out a couple times she gave a
very detailed breakdown of what happened
but congresswoman Omar said something
the other day that I felt found very
problematic as well because it was kind
of like the New York Times article where
it didn't present the full case exactly
so what do you think those people like
where where are they at if it's not
about a problem here if it isn't about
abortion your fellow sisters are
literally getting beaten to death by the
morality police yeah where are you at
where's the March where's the uprise
where's the where's the going to the
streets I think somewhere in Canada they
had a hundred I'm sorry sixty thousand
like it was amazing I don't see it here
and it's like if it's not about one
certain subject I don't think they they
really don't care saying one thing is is
one thing but I think getting out there
and getting in the streets I know Paula
you've been doing it I know uh now as
you've been doing it too but if it's
your if it's your
um if it's your rally cry so for example
my rally cries capitalism and free
enterprise and you know business and
freedom of speech that's my rally cry if
a topic comes around that I'm going to
talk about it like when PayPal came out
yesterday uh over the weekend they said
hey PayPal moving forward they're going
to find you 2 500 if uh anybody uh puts
any kind of misinformation out there I'm
like what is this guy put on Twitter and
then that wasn't fake that was actually
absolutely
no no they reverse
Yahoo came out and Yahoo said they
reversed their position saying they
can't do that and by the way if it was
fake PayPal lost six billion dollars
today wow oh did they market value but
see here's what happens with some people
are like yeah but that was Snopes that
never really happened this is happening
where it's concerning certain people and
people like wait a minute this is what's
going on for when you're saying this
feminist stuff there's a lot of women
that this is their rally cry yes your
rally cry is femini your rallycry is
woman you rally cry is that when you're
campaigning and those are the ones that
are quiet that's that's uh making people
feel yeah that's that's the word for
some people Yeah question so more says
we've seen this many times this isn't
like the first time that this has taken
place right this has been going on for
many times every time you know something
like this happens people are like oh
it's not going to happen you know it's
just another it's gonna last a day it's
gonna last a week it's gonna last two
weeks in the last three weeks eventually
it's gonna be this what is different
with this one than other protests we've
had in the past here's a different
never happened that 25 days morning to
night 24 hours people under age 30 that
they did not even born in the other
regime they're born in this regime never
happened I don't know if you heard that
news or not insist on eight kids got
killed they got shot from the back and
80 people total yeah
I mean they didn't even tell them run or
hey to turn around and they shoot them
they just shot them from the back these
things we believe when it gets to this
point everyone blood brings thousands of
Bloods up to go fight back these
families they're not gonna stop this
time it's a matter of Do or Die we can
feel it this time like I'm in touch with
uh Iran almost every night
almost every night we're talking we can
feel the language you know when you when
you're all the same when you look at the
eyes eyes talking of course I can't feel
it when I'm talking to them I can feel
it this time is different for many
reason is different many reasons they
have nothing to lose anymore you got to
be scared of the people they have
nothing to lose that's a good point yeah
and more to zojan there also
um uh banding together to shut down
businesses like uh from all sectors
there's uh oil and gas people that's
testing today they're striking and um
some students are striking uh
yeah closing down there so so I'm
reading this book called from
dictatorship to democracy I just
finished by Gene sharp he died four
years ago or something like that
fascinating story and he breaks down the
187 things you got to do to have a
peaceful Revolution to go from a you
know dictatorship to a democracy which
theocracy in other words that's pretty
much a dictatorship they have over there
right now you don't have a voice you
don't have freedom anything can be taken
away from me it's a very different kind
of an environment but his argument is
this has to be a peaceful Revolution
peaceful protesting it can't be violent
it's like the whole story with MLK
versus Malcolm X one wanted to do it
peaceful the other one had to you know
go more on the violent uh direction do
you think the Iranian people can pull
this off peacefully or are they going to
need help for someone to support them to
be where it's going to get pretty
violent Patrick John when he get to the
point that the starting three days ago
they're taking Criminal
prisoners out yeah and give them a
weapon to fight the protest give them a
chain to fight the protesters
regime opened the jails criminal jails
people that they killed people now they
give them promise of lowering their uh
you know jail time or often for the
death or whatever and put them in the
street there's also reports of um which
the regime in Iran has done this before
they bring in forces from Lebanon and
surrounding countries um because some
people say that it's it's easier for
them to beat and kill Iranians because
it's not there it's not their people
their country women and men so that's
happening too because there's photos
circulating of their uniforms their
videos and the videos of the talking
Arabic yeah yeah they're saying that uh
you're in my land and you're telling me
what I can do in my own country get out
of my country and they're speaking even
the police or whatever they're not even
wearing anything some of them are just
in uh casual clothes but going back to
going back to the question to all of you
and you know violent peaceful protest is
is the method of peaceful protesting can
that Prevail long term no you don't
think okay so tell me why I just feel
like and also for a diaspora Iranian to
be sitting out here I can never tell
people in Iran what to do because I'm
not there no questions yeah so what I'm
just saying is when um because I've seen
people inside of Iran say this in a more
eloquent articulate way but essentially
if you're if the state is meeting us
with repression and violence that's how
we're going to respond back and that's
what you're seeing okay fine so how do
you do that without weapons because over
there it's not Second Amendment it's not
like America where they believe in
Second Amendment which by the way times
like this kind of validates kind of need
a gun here and there to protect myself
against the government that tries to do
this to me uh but uh how do you do that
if you don't have access to guns and
weapons and that's a major problem
because people thinking army would join
them one of these days well guess what
the head of the army are selected from
the high generals of separ start on they
put him on the top of the army we heard
last week there are five of each group
higher ended the rank they got the uh
basically a sesame because they were
thinking or talking with each other for
something like that yeah here's the
point right now people they're hoping
that they get the lower rank this side
and if you see stone and rock is against
the tear gas and bullet people assume
the people like we the people not the
government police forces come to their
side hoping that police forces come to
their side which I believe is one thing
that a lot of people say outside of Iran
inside that that's what they need
absolutely and by the way you know what
this book said the book said when large
institutions unions organizations turn
against the government that's when they
start losing so it's not just the people
so it's like when you're talking about
businesses yes oil things like that
that's kind of the direction it needs to
go to for some of that to be taking
place but you're saying there's
regardless of what happens it's gonna go
through violence it's not going to have
a it's not gonna be successful as a
peace report protein way past it so let
me ask you was the 79 one a peaceful
protest when they got the shot or was it
was it violent it was peaceful so maybe
peaceful could work because being too
violent also it worked against the Shah
Patrick John this regime is dirtier than
the Shah it's the worst regime in the
history you don't find any King any
dictator did what they did to the
country and to the people you know
what's crazy you know so I was on the
show with uh fardot farroza good looking
guy I don't know if you guys
so he had me on last week and we're
talking and he asked me the weirdest
question because I did a video about
Iran like a couple years ago U.S Iran
history of conflict and he said you know
in your timeline again I'm paraphrasing
because he asked it enforcing there was
a translator I speak Farsi but I don't
speak it fluently to speak on the
channel uh in Farsi so he says you said
that when Iran needs help and for
whatever reason Democrats don't help uh
Iran to have a democracy Republicans do
and I said they're not saying his story
says I'm just saying case study yeah the
closest thing to Joe Biden ever is Jimmy
Carter and the closest thing to Jimmy
Carter ever is Joe Biden did you hear
Michelle Obama or Opera no say anything
no no but this is happening again you're
specifically talking Carter Biden
specifically talking Carter Biden right
because uh you know uh on the outside
Carter was sold as a what Carter
everyone who knows Carter says good
things about Carter as a person left
right middle doesn't matter as a human
being pacifist yeah but when you talk
about as a leader Scott was not a leader
decision maker he wasn't he was just a
very good Christian family man you know
just the kind of a guy that say you know
if you're going to be like a man be like
this person he's a good man right but
when it comes down to decisions like
this he didn't make the decisions that
he needed to make Kissinger himself they
could have helped they didn't get
involved right and then you have Biden
Biden being where he's at right now and
you know they're they have a bunch of
other sets of issues that they're
dealing with focus is more on Ukraine
Less on Iran you know Ukraine's the main
focus right now because of Russia all
that stuff hey 50 billion here 60
billion here and then Biden agreed to
give another seven billion dollars I
believe last week where the
conversations taking place and now
everyone's saying well the whole thing's
going to change when they get back to
the jcpoa negotiation to kind of nuclear
because we have to give them what they
want so this thing can kind of go away
which is I don't understand that
argument to take the position of let's
give them what they want so the regime
is going to be happier and calmer right
what are your thoughts when you're
hearing this of U.S not being as
involved to help the people where maybe
in other times they got a little bit
more help than they're getting right now
you're talking about Iran right yeah I'm
talking about like because you know for
them to do what they want to do they're
going to need some sort of a help
outside the people or not the government
so there's a big difference like for
example if we're talking uh if we're
talking uh Armenia against Azerbaijan
okay the The Armenian people and the
government The Armenian people are not
revolting against him they're on the
same page they need help here's money
Ukraine is like dude we're on the same
page we need help they're attacking us
right but Iranian people their
government is hurting them so a regime
has to come in and help the people out
and it's not happening why is Iran not
helping out United States sold over
trillion dollars after brought Khomeini
to Iran it's not in there you said they
sold they sold trillion dollars of arm
in last 43 years to the Middle Eastern
Area because of their making one country
scary hey you gotta buy this against
them hey you're gonna buy this weapon
against that's what is happening Iran I
mean with how many come to Iran seven
War happened 48 million refugees one and
a half a million killed over 3 million
disabled this is a gift of one mistake
United States foreign policy should
change must change enough already making
algode support algoritha give him so
much money and then they they give
against them enough making uh Boko Haram
or whatever all those ices and all of
them and then later on turning against
to become a terrorist of the uh area
if you're going back and you see what
these things happening is a mistake of
foreign policy of the United States but
there are a lot of Iranians there are a
lot of Iranians that also I hear from
that don't want foreign intervention
because a lot of people do see the
reason we're even here is because of
foreign intervention partially so there
is that argument too that has to come
from within how it's going to come from
within I also don't have the answer but
but there's a difference because uh
and here's how I see the foreign
intervention the the difference between
there's another documentary that uh uh
why uh the revolution of Iran happened
talking about what they did to the shop
because Shah was becoming too powerful
for example
if
if you're living in a society where the
the people at the top are abusing people
okay say you and I are here we go to a
restaurant okay
we see a guy that's hitting a girl slaps
her in the face what are you going to
tell me to do so if I can tell you I'm
gonna go interview that's right so it's
so but should we intervene I would but
should we yes so we should yes but yes
but wait a minute that's different but
no it's not it's not different because
in this situation 12 year olds are
getting killed yeah okay so it's not
like with the Shah Shah was killing 12
year olds it's not like the Shah was
forcing 52 year olds to marry nine it's
a very different perspective for you
then but let me wrap this coin up so for
me you know in a in a in a situation
like this these are two different
situations if my my sister is married to
her husband they're having a fight it's
not my business I'm not intervening zero
if my wife and I are having a fight my
dad lives with my my dad's biggest
reason why he didn't want to live with
us for 10 years I've been trying to get
this guy to live with us you know what's
the number one reason
I don't want to come in between you and
your wife never like if we fight guess
what my dad does goes upstairs he goes
to his room he says it's your business
yeah okay he goes it's your business no
problem but I tell you if I even it's
never happened it's not but if if I did
something he's the first one that's
going to come in and say I'm intervening
right so I think you know as much as you
say some Iranians are saying that I
understand it's like the Diplomatic
politically correct thing to say for
some not saying all of them some of them
want to say something like that this is
a very different situation they're
currently in right now well I'm not
talking about diaspora Iranian saying
this I'm talking about Iranians inside
everyone but my question to you was if
you you are saying they need
intervention so how do you propose that
to happen what can even happen how can
you get anything I think we gotta we the
United States has to be the number one
to step up they got to put sanction on
it we always do sanctions on Russia and
everybody we got to get Hands-On because
like you said if it's going to be rocks
against bullets they're not gonna I love
them to death and I'm with them 100
you're not going to win that battle and
I I don't know here's my question you
guys why aren't we getting as involved
with not like like Ukraine and all this
why are we because they're trying to
negotiate the Jason that's what I was
gonna yeah I mean that's my that's what
I would think is happening so do you
have an answer that you guys have an
answer because I have a rebottle here
okay so let me let me give my feedback
to you on how to help on something like
that and I I know it's not going to be a
popular one for you because of where you
lean politically but I'll give it to you
so you know sometimes uh um
um Paulette for instance I was the
annoying younger brother super
protective okay
I'm exactly who you think I was so when
my sister would date guys
uh you know it was just a bad situation
she did not want me around right because
my parents got a divorce so naturally
from 10 years old when they got a
divorce I was the brother I was supposed
I have to play that role naturally no
problem
so when when you have somebody annoying
like that in your life you don't want
them around too much because it's like
man let me just live my life and just
don't bother me right until all of a
sudden
something happens with there's really a
need then you say you know what this is
a situation where I wish that brother of
mine that was like that would be here to
protect me against XYZ is that 90 of the
time no it's ten percent of the time
when uh uh Trump was President okay
put sanctions on top of sanctions on top
of sanctions on top of sanctions on top
of sanctions on top of sanctions to the
point where Iran was about to go through
the revolution it was very close whether
we got about to go to the revolution
and he says no we support the Iranian
people no we support the Iranian people
he pulled out at 150 billion dollars
with Kerry and Obama said no we're not
going to be doing this pulled out pulled
up pulled out we're not going to be
doing this we're not going to be doing
this we're not going to be doing this
and then the moment the regime changes
no this is back on the table let's talk
about it we're removing this we're
removing that and then they start
getting free I was in Monaco one time
and we're having
can't give mention the person's name but
the person is involved in the economy of
the 21 countries that they're dealing
with the economy and all this stuff says
listen the moment sanctions were given
we had to call every Bank in the Middle
East to say you can't do any business
with people in Iran he says it was legit
when that took place like when you're
saying business is shutting down oil
shutting down you got to bring the pain
to the government right unfortunately
the current regime can do that but
they're not doing that and they're
playing negotiation there's a famous guy
back in the days his name was Ronald he
says you don't negotiate with terrorists
we've been negotiating with terrorists
for too long and I don't think you
should negotiate with terrorists a lot
of people agree with you yeah and
there's uh messages that we get from
inside of Iran that say we know things
are bad and yeah the economy sucks but
we want you guys to put pressure on your
politicians to not renegotiate this deal
we will suffer a little longer and they
say a lot of people promise
we just want your support that's not
even a dollar of it come to Iran right
to the people that goes directly from
the account you account to the
terrorists outside the countries and the
funny thing is none of those countries
sit one one thing about what is
happening in Iran neither Surya or
Palestine or none of them who who in
that area besides us because it's always
us we're the world's police but like
like you said there's you know conflict
of interest right now who else can step
in and and help I mean that there's you
know who is it always going to be just
us nobody else is trying like you just
said when you say assuming America
America where we I mean normally we help
with everything where our hand is
everywhere 160 whatever countries we
have bases everywhere nobody else nobody
has a base here we're spread out who
else in that area could try to help like
nobody's nobody stepping up they didn't
leave any friends around they just
supported all the terrorist groups in
each country the government of every
single country around us are the enemy
of us yeah I mean think about it two
times they uh trucks 18 trucks of gold
and dollars that were going illegally to
Turkish to come out and go to any of
their private Banks Turkish got it
nobody said this is ours
it was few hundred billion dollars with
the goals and dollars they're like
fantastic we have a budget for a few
years of our country nobody claimed it
this is crazy that like how many
trillions of dollars they stole out of
that country and still that country is
standing imagine what a rich country it
was yep well an analyst also had
speculated to me that
um
you know other countries in the region
aren't going to come out strongly in
support of the Iranian people in their
fight for freedom because then they'll
get worried that oh this could happen in
our country too yeah
right yeah they were going to want a
revolution so okay so let's just say the
revolution does happen Okay let's just
say this is a different one and it's
going to actually take place okay
who's running the place what's the form
of the government who steps up you know
who are uh some names you you know for
the longest time you know many of the uh
Iranians who love the shot they're like
you know his son is going to go back and
Farah and Reza palavi and they're going
to go back and you know that's what's
gonna happen you're hearing the news you
know soccer player legendary soccer
player Ali Academy you know going around
saying what he's saying because
typically when you do have a revolution
a British Diplomat wrote a book like 20
years 15 years ago called leaderless
Revolution who's the leader today right
it's a leaderless revolution right it's
like the prime example of there's a
revolution taking place without leader
what's gonna happen if this revolution
does take place this is the biggest
characteristics that this event has it
right now which is why it's literally
there is an event going on 25 days in a
country with no exact or no person as a
leading it and here's the problem with
in my opinion from the outside the
country leaders or even inside the
country imagine a one row one-way line
bridge and you're parking at the middle
of it you're not backing up that people
go and you're not going forward that
people some of our leaders are standing
at the middle of the bridge and they're
not letting people one day they are king
one day they are not King one day they
want to be completed one day they don't
want one day they're a resident they
announced that I'm just a resident this
thing is not we can't count on the
people that there are on
outside the country I believe that next
future leader of the country would be a
possibly a lady
from the street after you think so I
look at what the girls are doing that's
amazing look at what the teenage girls
they're leading the charge right now oh
my God that'd be great having
demonstrating you know yeah I mean but
but you know how uh uh when there's a
crisis leaders rise up and you kind of
identify certain names like hey you look
at what happened here boom who's this
person never knew this person overnight
we know the person are there some names
that are being you know identified who
are getting their voices to get louder
and louder I haven't heard it and also
it's I would say even if I had it's
dangerous to say it because you're just
giving something away and like oh well
then we're gonna go watch this person I
understand that no but what do you say
when you said Ali Karimi I think people
half joke and half think well he would
be great if he could come back and do
that right
um no but I have also heard people say
just this is not anything formal this is
just like oh this would be cool if this
happened but there's a human rights
lawyer that famously has never left the
country and they jail her all the time
for defending human
and you said a female people have been
like well she'd be great if you know she
could leave Iran out of all the
countries is ready to have an A Woman as
a president well not in the current
government no no no of course once the
revolution happens you think it's
capable to do that and if you do uh
Khomeini came in he killed two thousand
of Shahs generals and military leaders
what do you do if you do take over
Hezbollah they're still there morality
police people are still there what do
you do them jailed them like a hundred
thousand people gonna go to jail I mean
that's a because those if they're still
out there they're gonna do what their
job is to do are they going to escape
and go to you know where are they going
to go to what do you do with those folks
well the Imperial Army when Shaw left a
lot of them just switched over they're
like okay well I guess you're not
allowed no no he killed a lot of he
killed like a couple thousand of them
and a lot of them top ones yeah they got
the top ones yeah well yeah I mean those
are the main ones you gotta figure out
because you you need your lieutenants
you need your generals but uh what
happens with that what do you do with
that do you what happens with the
Hezbollah laws what happens with these
you know these people you know history
shows during the Mosaic time
and uh even a couple of times after that
that these people they have a fantastic
Talent of over the night changing face
we saw that at 11 40 a.m people were in
the street that will show
the 20 two months passed between the
people saying people say this the
opposite things 20 minutes later when
that happened what do you mean by that
so you're saying that you could change
their minds is what you're saying many
people look at our celebrities look at
our celebrities in past month
I have the Farsi page as
as soon as I came out of the country on
Facebook
I contacted many celebrities that about
this matter you want to say something
about this matter you want to say
something nothing nothing
now last 15-20 days they feel like oh it
looks like this is serious they start
saying so and some of them still they're
not
clearing their position they're just
saying something between Despair and
David
that I don't I don't say that uh taking
aside
it's not a Time to Say
uh I'm personally sure I'm touchy I'm
the you know a soccer team soccer teams
which side it's a matter right now you
have sheriff or your bisharaph that's it
right that's it and they threatened shut
up be shut off can you explain what no I
can't it's just having having wise and
having shame yeah so if you are be shut
off you have no no shame yeah
and the artists do get threatened and
their families get threatened and I know
they've taken people's passports away so
they can't leave the country so we yes
it would be and a lot of them have
spoken out and then they get threatened
and so it's like they try to do it and
they can't go past a certain point
because of what's being
told that will happen to them and their
families so yeah you know what I mean
uh just made a song with everybody's
tweets I don't know if you heard that of
course and so they caught him they
captured him and then his video came out
uh I guess yesterday and in his video he
just wanted to let everyone know that
I'm okay nothing's happened it was a
miscon misunderstanding uh that they
thought perhaps I'm with the other
governments outside of Iran but you know
it's not and instead of giving me money
a lot of Iranians are supporting my
music and you're sending me money send a
funds to mahak yeah
and at the end I'm okay I'm not taking
any podcast I'm not at this point at all
and you could see that it's scripted
same thing that happened in China with
Jack ma when Jack Mullen disappearing
for three months yeah
so when you ask and by the way the song
rivet first time by the way the first
time I heard it I'm like oh my God I had
to just listen to it it's unbelievable
but go ahead you were saying so when
you're thinking when you're saying how
come we're not helping you around right
think about Iran Russia China
right they're all working together so if
you have one country that has mess then
what happens your power it's all power
play who we can help and who we can't
play help and by the way if America
wants to help Iran who's the who's going
to get the money the government that's
not going to help the people yeah
exactly that's not going to help so
who's the person there is no person
so just it's just the movement and you
can't just give give money and these
these take time too yeah for sure yeah
so maybe something will emerge
for them weeks and months me too because
it's not letting down
and like we said the this when you have
school girls that are this defiant in
the face of authority and they don't
care and they're out in the streets
getting murdered and beaten and going in
the faces of police and any authority
figure taking off their head jobs you
know that this is like there's no
turning back from this and like
mortization said they feel like there's
nothing to lose we literally live under
the worst oppression so what worse Could
Happen yep
so one of their chant is that until our
last Blood were not given up on this
movement that's their like I don't say
it exactly how they say it Farsi they
have nothing to lose yeah
that's where they are no wedding you
can't find anybody does what they did to
our country in 43 years in a history of
human being you can't find it I was with
you in Irvine you guys were doing
protesting you were in La the day before
how big are these protests getting in
L.A in Irvine uh it's getting bigger and
bigger bigger and bigger yesterday uh
Sunday we had the event at the Mission
Viejo it's a little city somewhere
around three four thousand people over
there yeah our event in La was a little
over 20 000. because I was I was helping
and then that afternoon we drove in the
streets yeah we were started uh downtown
at uh City Hall and um marched and it
was I mean you can see there's aerial
shots and 151 cities participate in this
game I should point out it was started
by Hamed es Malian who lost his daughter
and um wife in the flight 752 which was
shot down by the irgc and he started
this movement and it's because of him
that we had the global day of action for
Iran and 151 cities I mean that's a lot
of global support
you know I I hope this is the one area
where you know everybody it doesn't
matter which side you're on politically
everybody you're nice to say look man I
don't care which one you voted for or
not if there's one thing we agree on I'd
like to see democracy get back into Iran
where we can be uh free and go back and
visit a place like this it seems like if
there's one thing hopefully people can
stay unified on it seemed like so far
it's looking good to do something with
this but we're going to see what's going
to happen by the way so just out of
curiosity this is a topic that comes up
all the time I've spent time with Reza
pallavi a couple times the sun in DC
we've had a meeting together we sat down
we talked about his father we did a zoom
a couple years ago when we've spoken or
you should have them on you should have
money you should have money on he's out
there very you know eloquent great
speaker does very good job but the the
audience is 50 50. if you look at his
social media it gets a lot of people
gets a lot of commentary he gets a lot
of people that still
follow him you know a very loyal to his
messaging but what what is the
perspective of Reza pallavi's you know
his son RP uh how do the Persian Iranian
people view him
any one of you guys can take this one if
you're well I live in LA okay so la
leans toward more monarchists but
there's also a lot of people like me who
aren't aligned or affiliated with any
group ideology or person we just want
freedom for Iran and I know um some some
of the people in his Camp have said look
he just would like to be a part of the
Democracy in an election and if they
vote for him great and if they don't
it'll be somebody else so there's kind
of different camps and there is
definitely split support that's what
I've seen
oh yeah I agree uh when the last couple
of times he cleared his vision about you
know what I want to be a citizen and if
people wanted me to run the country no
problem uh then you guys select it right
this made the so much clearer for people
that are thinking like only King only it
is coming this this way now people know
that we talk about absolute democracy
absolute democracy when regime change
everybody vote on what they want to do
I think it's more 50 50 because I don't
know if the younger people feel he can
relate to their pain because he's lived
in America and and you know I think the
generation that knows his father more
they're probably saying oh we would like
that back but the younger generation I
don't know
I'm not 100 I would agree with that as
well
you don't know if the younger generation
which is very valid on why that would be
the case well listen to their chance too
the younger generation is just saying
freedom deaths of the dictator regime
don't be scared we're all together so
that I just feel like if we listen to
their chance we can hear what they want
freedom secularism secular democracy but
there's not one person's name some
people say it in Iran but the majority
are not saying one person's name it's
kind of like for example we moved to
Florida right and I was having a
conversation with SIA and then we we
talk about California how we miss
California but we miss California post
covet because that's the California we
know California is different for us now
because we're so used to Florida are you
kidding me and I feel like for example
the older generation remembers how Iran
was with Shaw and palavi all of that and
they're hoping that comes back but is
there a connection with the youth is he
making is RP making connection with the
youth or whenever there is uprise that's
when he shows up that's the whole
question got it so you know some view as
an opportunist hey come out here say a
few things some say no we want them here
because we'd like to go back and see
what Iran once used to be the chance of
Iran going back to a monarchy is slim to
none it's not that it's not going to be
a monarch the only thing that's going to
happen is a again my opinion I'm just
talking from my perspective here on what
I'm saying uh uh democracy is the only
uh uh in order for him to take it back
to monarchy I feel you can't be
disconnected for 43 that's a long time
for it to happen again so again no one
knows you'll see what happened if it
comes down to the election that's who
they want it is what it is if it doesn't
it won't happen I think some people
experienced 1400 years ago Islam uh
that's enough for them they don't want
to go experience 250 years ago myarchy
yeah again
it's time for democracy
and freedom but what does democracy look
like
what did we find out
how do you live here no I understand but
think about 44 years of Oppression how
do you gradually do that right how how
what does it look like how long does it
take because it's not going to happen
overnight think about it of course it's
not it is not overnight of course it's
not gonna happen overnight it's gonna
take a while yeah
but it is possible because it's
different type of movement this time
than the green green movement and green
movement I feel like I actually was in
Iran when that happened I got to Iran
two days before the election with
ahmadine musavi and it was when I when
we landed we were out of the airport in
Tehran at 2 A.M and we're driving
through the streets and everybody's out
dancing there's green everywhere because
that was the color of the movement music
and I was like so shocked I asked my
family I was like this is happening here
this is legal right now and they're like
well yeah it's before the election so
they want everybody to feel this energy
and everybody really felt energized and
we all saw what happened it was a rigged
election obviously and I just went to
Ahmed but those and I was there for the
couple weeks after so I saw what
happened but it did kind of get quashed
pretty quickly this one has sustained
and it's showing no signs of slowing
down especially because we're talking
about different sectors of businesses
now joining together
um to protest so that's one big
difference another one is like how young
the people are that are engaged and
moving this forward to like teenagers
were saying you know I just I haven't
seen it be this sustained because we've
had protests happen but Alban happened
that was the November bloody November in
2019 or 1500 people that we know of
weren't killed
um and then that because the internet
got throttled and cut off and the world
wasn't paying the attention is now that
also got quelled really easily and this
one is not this one's growing more Let
me let me ask you you guys remember you
know uh
what's that one song We Are the World
you know the whole USA for Africa us for
Africa the song uh if somebody does want
to you know do an event like that to
raise money who does the money go to who
do you trust to send the money to are
there any organizations that you know
you can support are there ones that
people trust that is actually going to
make it in there you know sometimes the
biggest criticism is when the money
never makes it to the real people the
ones in the middle keep most of the
money so be careful who you give your
money to yeah the center of human rights
in Iran that's all I swear to God and
ask you if we're sending that money
where who's gonna get it does it go
directly to them or is the government
involved there's a couple that came out
um I wish I had my phone with me but um
I can find the link but there are a
couple like Iran human rights Center for
human rights and they use the money to I
believe what it says is to actually just
help
promote some freedoms and democracy for
Iran and they work on like I don't want
to misspeak for them but they use it
it's not going
you can't just send money to Iran anyway
and there's certain ways that you can
get money to uh charity organizations
and stuff there's also an Amnesty
International petition that's going
around I know one of the human rights
attorneys that's a part of the effort
that people are trying to get signed so
that it puts pressure on the UN and the
International Community to create an
international mechanism to investigate
crimes against humanity from these
officials and uh to go after their
assets in other countries especially
where their kids live so they're trying
to get them to not be able to travel to
have you know them and their kids not be
able to have property
freeze their money and that's one way to
get to them and try them for crimes it's
one way to get to who to the officials
of Iran who are in charge of you know
giving these orders it's basically like
a way to sanction them to freeze their
assets to allow them not to travel
freely to like U.S Canada Europe
yeah
um okay did you guys know one or no like
where the money goes to because
sometimes like like right now for
example I'm having a what's that again
they should say it somewhere around
there that's the one I'll be wrong yeah
that's it we got some people but they
cannot accept big money they're going to
get endangered of course so we passed
three weeks we got some channels that be
sent little by little five thousand ten
thousand five thousand that's not bad
and yeah and mostly goes for the doctors
and you know people that they are giving
help
the spending for the medical staff for
the people they get shot and so on so on
they're underground what do you guys
think about Christina Christian amanpur
what do you guys think about her with
CNN she hasn't has she even said
anything about this yeah what do you
think about her in general yeah well you
know the whole thing she was supposed to
do an interview with raisi and then uh
you know he said you have to wear the
hijab and she said I've done interviews
for the last Cardinals how many years 20
some years 30 years I've never worn the
hijab says now I'm not showing up to the
interview if you don't wear the hijab
and she doesn't there's a picture of her
if you want to put it up with her not
wearing the hijab with an empty chair
it's uh the empty chair picture I don't
know if you have that or not type an
empty chair uh yeah rice is fun
it's right there to the right there you
go that's the picture right there and he
doesn't show up wow but then she does
this then a couple days later she tweets
and says you know retweets the article
about New York Times and I think she
pins it to the top then she unpinned it
about the fact that the issues is taking
place in Iran is economy it's not really
you know what's going on with women and
hijab and all this it's more of an
economical issue that's going on why why
is it so here's a by the way I don't
know if you guys know or not so for some
of you guys that just joined us we have
some money on the panel right now that
minor the media criticism if you guys
are familiar with that there's a minor
called media criticism and we're going
to go to see if she can criticize some
of the media or not so for the expert on
a panel that's a media criticism
[Laughter]
why is it CNN New York Times why is it
that some of these stories like you're
just tell the story on what's going on
rather than playing politics with some
of this stuff what is their biggest
hesitation to say Russia Putin is Hitler
but in Iran that's not really as bad
it's really only economical but but
Putin is Hitler's second coming of you
know Hitler is going to be why do they
why do they turn people like him into
such you know you know terrible leader
Ukraine Heroes but Iran has more
economical situation.com what do you
think they're doing that why are they
playing politics
um I can't speak to Putin but um CNN has
stepped up their coverage in the last
week I've seen Jake Tapper covers it
almost nightly and they are showing the
videos they were one of the first people
that I think that showed what was
happening at shadif University and the
violence that was in the Crackdown that
was happening on the students so I will
say they have stepped up Cristiano
Ronaldo just interviewed um sheeting
ebadi who is the first female in the
Middle East to win a Nobel Peace Prize
and did a you know her basic uh ending
message was she asked Miss ebony what do
you think should happen uh she said yeah
has to be a regime change so they're
saying it and they're showing it now
other networks need to follow suit
I didn't find I know some people found
this problematic I felt like she was
making a statement and on this yeah no I
love that she did this okay
yeah this was great of course because
the visual was no absolutely I want her
to do more of this show this like hey
why should women you know the whole
concept about if you don't wear a hijab
is like a woman walking around naked
that's the that's what Khomeini said in
79 that a woman not wearing a hijab is
the same as a woman walking around naked
I mean and for some people to say well
that's that's the norm here we believe
that
I like this I like the stand she took
with this one and this was right right
in the thick of I think it was just a
few days after massagina died and so she
was like of course and and they're on
American soil so it's different if she
was in Iran I'm sure she would have put
it on because oh she said that yeah
she's like I'm not doing it in America
not an American soul but that's that
you're in our country why am I supposed
to wear the the laws are here on my side
uh Patty John I have nothing against a
Christian I'm a poor she was born in our
street who are like neighbor
but generally and originally if you ask
majority of the Persian people
they see the origin of the Shia
branch of Islam just created by UK
there's a history on it exactly how they
send it how they designed it how uh
those majulacies showed up
above and above and they they just
trained to speak for us everybody knows
about the uh
role that UK played Behind The Shield
so Persian people originally don't have
a good opinion about the CNN especially
what happened in the first 79. you think
that yeah most persons to me are
Democrats most Persians are CNN driven
it's pretty split these days I think
it's 60 40 is for my feeling I mean when
I was in LA have you seen the last week
purchased right in front of the CNN
building in Sunset what do I do five
thousand people there yeah but I but I
think for the most part most Iranians
60 I'll go 60 40. most of them are
Democrats so I would I would assume
that's like this we lean liberal in the
States but why do they though
why do Iranians lean liberal in the
states what's I don't know I don't know
I'm curious to know but is it does that
have anything to do with Iran or is it
more to do just pure philosophy I lean
not lean I am because of domestic
policies in the United States so I
believe in I'm pro-choice I'm lgbtq
rights I'm black lives matter so that's
me internationally with Iran I think the
Democrats have screwed up the response
not everybody is Unified in what they're
saying against Iran so I'm disappointed
in that but yeah I mean most of us are
Democrats of course because of we live
in America so that's what we want for
this country when it comes to Iran I can
see why there are I I have I know people
that socially are liberal in the U.S but
they have voted Republican because of
the Republicans harder stance toward
Iran
did you know what happened with black
lives matter just in the last couple
weeks with the owner the funds yeah I
did hear some stories what do you think
about that
um which one are you speaking about in
specific I just want to make sure
the uh the founder got indicted uh to
Kanye coming out talking about white
lives matter Kanye I just can't with him
right now three three uh Osborne
Osborne 900 900 000. interviewing her
and she says look I wish Kanye would
have told me black lives matter was a
scam we gave him nine hundred thousand
dollars you know so so what happens here
is the following you're an educated
person you went to a great University
you speak eloquently you're somebody
that's you know and and a lot of us you
know in in you know you're hearing like
okay
black lives matter basic concept of
course it matters yeah white lives
matter of course it matters all lives
matter of course it matters that's but
that wasn't the point of black lives
matter well no no the saying listen ing
but I'm curious I'm also not talking
about an organization right now I'm
talking about a movement well the
movement but but the leaders behind the
movement so we get the organization has
just been corrupt and they're not
helping any black lives in the community
they're just taking all the money and
spending it on themselves uh Candace
someone just did the thing where they
raised 80 million dollars what is it
what's it helping what do they what are
they helping in the community here's the
biggest part here's the biggest part
here's the biggest part where
credibility is lost my opinion
break this apart when I give this to you
okay
what is the job of MSNBC or CNN or fox
or CBS or these guys that are
investigative journalists right
how long does it take to find out it's a
[ __ ] show within a organization it's
your job to do that but if you don't do
that blindly you just go out there and
say yeah here's what it is usually and
then this happens you know what happens
you lose credibility people don't trust
the media when you say stuff and CNN's
rating is in such shambles right now
that they had to fire the guy fire a
bunch of their hosts they don't know
what the hell to do Brian Williams that
was maybe their best guy that they had
he's he decided to step away cannot even
believe what's going on I was a cromo
guy I thought Cuomo was doing a uh
decent job take his brother out and any
of the me too I don't The credibility
behind some of the metoo movement with
him take that I'm not talking about that
I thought he was okay but
you realize what they what they did was
so so bad that they had to dramatically
change it because educated people who
went to school followed their truth and
announced like well we never you know
the Russia was a hoaxman but let's not
talk about it because of Durham you know
we know that was a hoax and it was
funded by Hillary let's not talk about
it Hunter's laptop let's talk let's not
talk about hunter's laptop let's talk
about it two days afterwards election no
no let's not talk there is no investing
so credibility is gone because they
never talk what do you mean they did bad
stuff you said they did so many bad what
did you what are you referring to with
CNN you said CNN did so many bad things
everything I just listed to you well I
mean if we're gonna talk about networks
Fox News does the same thing it's just
on the other side so but then here's
what I would say to you here's what I
would say to you say you're right
let's say let's say you're right yeah
would you say you're right about CNN 2
or no about that they've engaged in what
I misinformation misinformation bias you
just hit him they're not reporting the
news they're holding back news so so I'm
sure there's a bias because they're
left-leaning no no it's not about bias
so here's the thing so how do you judge
a a uh I don't know how do you judge a
company that's going through problems
how do you judge a company how do you
judge a
how do you judge a bad restaurant
food food and service what else
if I if I say guys let's go to this
restaurant yeah
and lunchtime we go to this restaurant
what's the first way to judge at 12
o'clock that this restaurant may have a
problem if it's packed or MP if it's
packed and people say it sucks do you
believe it
no no let me ask a question one more
time if the restaurant is packed yeah
but people say it sucks do you believe
it no no if they say it's awesome I I
understand why you would no I mean I've
been to a restaurant they got raised
reviews and they didn't have good food
if a restaurant is typically bad it's
empty yeah if a restaurant is good it's
full unless the Ambiance is great no I
don't know about that so CNN is CNN is
the restaurant that's empty and fox is
full right now unfortunately for some
people we have ratings numbers to look
at oh my God
Tucker Carlson is the most watched also
on television well that's sad and I
don't know don't just pull up Tucker
just pull up rating for all um
no but you just said you know you
brought up I don't bring it up you said
black lives matter CNN I never once said
black lives matter you know black lives
matter you brought up CNN so from black
lives no no you asked why are you now
why are you concerned about this man you
asked you said can we see ratings wait
for you no you said can I finish for her
and show some ratings you said why do
Iranians vote Democrat and I said
because of social issues in the United
States and then I listed a few and you
harped on black lives matter I said
lgbtq rights I said pro-choice I get
that you chose black lives matter sure I
mean and then we got to CNN somehow and
now we're looking at Tucker Boston's
ugly because because again that's the
problem but you see what you just said
right there is I think the issue well I
think I think the issue is like for
example
Stephen A Smith I don't know if you know
who he is or not yes Stephen A Smith is
ESPN guy right he's like he's like the
Stephen A Smith is like the Tucker of
fox or the Mad out of MSNBC or the
morning Joe or I've seen this we know
who he is you know what it just did let
me tell you what he just did which I
need I think we need more of this
so he just launches a podcast
do you know his first guess no Chris
Cuomo do you know his second guest
Tucker Carlson
well that's just ratings by the way no
no but let me tell you what happened
he's on uh what's the guy's name uh
Jesse Waters what some people love Jesse
Waters some hate Jesse Waters right he
was a guy that was part of Jesse Waters
Jesse Waters was part of Bill O'Reilly's
guy that he would go man on the street
it was Jessie oh okay okay so anyways
so he does first podcast Chris Cuomo
second podcast he does with Sean Hannity
he's on Jesse Waters promoting his
podcast two days ago Jesse says am I
your favorite host at Fox
Stephen A Smith thinks is no no I got it
I'm with Sean Sean Hatter is my favorite
host.fox I was like what hmm
he said that that on National
to Fox can we pull the clip up but but
can I can I tell you something can I
tell you something here's what I love
about this I love that because I think
like a guy's asked me a question about
this morning guys asked me a question
about uh uh uh I don't know he's asked
me a question about LeBron James what do
you think about LeBron James
I think LeBron could be unifier he's not
what do you think about Oprah Winfrey I
think she could be a unifier she's not
you know what made Obama's speech
freaking amazing at the DNC in 2004 what
it was so perfect that they did Chase
studies about it wrote books about it
because he says I don't care if you're
from Texas you're white you're black
you're Hispanic you're this you're that
this is United States let's figure out a
way to make it work together right well
how are LeBron and Oprah not unifying
they're not they're they're no way you
think LeBron's a unifier in America no
way how are in the NBA you you have to
be a Democrat to be in the NBA of course
the NBA you know named me a One open
Republican in the NBA go ahead I'll wait
I'm not because
follow them
but there's none but you know how it is
in baseball no one gives a [ __ ] nobody
cares like no one gives a [ __ ] the best
players in baseball are like dude let's
just play the game let's just talk you
know nobody's making basketball
political what do you mean
show me the stats if you have it for
ratings for everybody so not like this
one the one that shows everything is
also I feel like in flux they fired a
bunch of people and they're trying to
figure out their Vibe why do you think
are we gonna go but it was like that of
Europe are we gonna go left right center
they're gonna be super center by the way
but do you know why CNN was like I'm not
defending CNN I understand what I'm
saying to you is what made CNN so
powerful is a guy named Ted Turner
started it yeah and you know how we
finished it in this book the last
chapter of his book everybody has to
read he's the one guy I do want to
interview but unfortunately he's not in
good health conditions we're in
communication with his Camp he we'd love
to interview him he's in a different
place when his book ends what it talks
about is how disappointed it he is in
the current product
because it's only one-sided you don't
hear air both sides of the story so it's
Fox News I I understand you're saying so
is Fox News but Fox will actually do
some digging and tell some stuff CNN
blindly says nope I don't agree with you
okay so let me ask a question three
years everybody in America thought
Russia hoax Russia was a real deal none
of it was they came in Russia was a real
Russia Russia Russia Trump
I'm not a matter of thinking I'm not
going to get into that because it has
nothing to do with Iran but it's it's
not it's not that we say that again but
I think this has a lot to do with Iran I
think this has everything to do with
Iran I'll answer to you I think it has
to do with Iran because
um
in order for there to be progress
we all have to question why we believe
what we believe in how much of it is
brainwashing how much of it is the way
we were brought up how much of it is
true how I was an atheist 25 years of my
life
purely I almost became a Scientologist
because I went to Scientology churches
regularly almost became a Mormon because
I was around incredible Mormon people
fantastic Mormon people when I tell you
great phenomenal Mormon people around me
so I said let me look into this then I
went and looked at Judaism I looked at
Jehovah's seven day I was curious I'm
going out there looking for it and I'm
like my dad wasn't going to church my
mother was not you know wasn't like part
of our you know like everyday life we've
I don't remember ever doing a Bible
study I don't remember ever doing
sitting on and saying okay kids let's
talk about you know you know such and
such no nothing nothing like that and
one day I'm like you know what this is
what I want to do politically my dad was
a uh what do you call it a uh
imperialist mother was a communist kind
of a family you think you raised in
that's a confusing communist divorce
twice in 20 years
parents got divorced twice in 20 years
our parents you know how you see all
these guys frisbee people that are
throwing frisbees down they threw you
know plates like frisbees in our house
it was so entertaining they could play
Frisbee with plates it was so
fascinating our family it was a very
peaceful marriage that they yeah yeah
sounds like it yeah yeah it's just very
very good so the point I'm trying to
make is on why this has to do with that
I think we all have to question every
time somebody says we can't say uh fox
said it it's got to be true if Siena
said it it's got to be true if this
person said it it's got to be true
because if CNN's restaurant is empty
there is a reason that's fine to say
that but I will never agree with the
fact that
Fox doesn't give you news with a slant
it's clearly biased of course I didn't
say they don't okay of course they do
I'm not saying they don't I never said
are you just talking ratings but but
here's what you still haven't seen but
here's the part uh I'll pull it up by
the while you're going through this
because this isn't the one there's a
ranking that they do that yeah
okay so let's go through this one MSNBC
second one Fox News channel cruise to
Victor and third quarter cable rooms
delivering an average Prime audience of
2.2 million easily outpacing MSNBC which
was distant second to 1.277 they're also
very sensationalist and that draws a
Crowd Oh my God that's what I think so
you were sensationalist with the New
York Times so you said you suck they
were but I loved it because it's true
but that article sucked so guess what
you were right you can be sensationalist
and right
yes I don't think fox is right though
but no they are right they are right
but again again I think my my biggest
thing is I've interviewed seven
Communists because I want to talk to
people that disagree with we should talk
to people that disagree with and I I
think you should go and sit down and
talk to Tucker Carlson I think I would
love it
he would regret it but it would be great
TV I think I I think I think you're
underestimating the power of a very uh
strong uh debater who knows his world
very well and knows the other person's
world as well sure uh very well I think
guys like him I think the opposite of
him was John stood at his Peak I love
Johnston I love Johnston I love John
Stewart but I also love Tucker so weird
I'm confusing do you not like it I
understand yeah but I think I love both
well you've got in the middle of the
road a lot but I but I Veer this way
yeah you know it's totally fine and
again all I'm saying is I think if we're
gonna go my my challenge right now is if
we're going in the direction that we're
going with Iran I would like to say
listen
you like the Lakers I like the clippers
but we both love Iran is that okay if we
just you enough in this area and we say
great high fives sure we're scored away
right so we don't have to agree on
everything but let's agree on this one
thing that we would like to see
democracy coming back to Iran let me
finish this data because I hate to have
guests on it which was third overall 717
amongst 25w demographics Fox News
outpaced and tuna by the way this must
be a foxnews.com website you don't want
to see the foxnews.com I feel like you
think I'm like on the board of CNN or
like my uncle owns it you know I don't
think that but what I do think is what I
do think is I think you're a very uh uh
powerful just look what happened to you
in the last week and and to me you know
you said something he said most of us
are kind of like you know careful on
what we say different reasons some has
to do with career the industry you're
part of you got to be careful because
you know uh maybe family traditions
values
not you I'm saying you said at the
beginning you said I said you know you
were very vocal recently said I've
always been not this vocal but you know
the risk of your career you said some
comments not my career yeah different
people have different fears of what they
say some for some it is career yes not
you for some it could be Korea yeah but
I think there's some people that got a
voice who are minor in uh media you know
criticism that should use the voice more
often and I think it's good for society
I think you guys like when I use my
voice when you like what I'm saying no I
I know but but I but I I don't care what
you say that I disagree with I want you
to say it yeah and then I want us to
have a friendly debate and let the
audience decide and we I don't care if
you agree if I agree with you or not
believe me I've had criminals here I've
had Mobsters here I've had people I
fully don't agree with but I want to
poke and ask the question and the
audience I screw you Pat I agree with
them I don't know no problem it's good
to go you get to decide for yourself I
don't like Tucker you like Tucker but we
want freedom for Iran but there you go
we're making friends today so this is a
friends 101 One Fine areas of agreement
common ground which is Iran so now let's
go back and finish it up with the last
10 15 minutes that we have here uh uh
how optimistic are you guys how
optimistic are you with uh how things
are uh going right now obviously it's
day 25 for us all we're doing is talking
about is day 25 for the people in there
it's day 25 and day 25 comes with a lot
of suffering and challenges and losses
and a lot of different methods ugly
right how optimistic are you that this
could be the one I know we talked about
it briefly a minute ago but how
optimistic are you that this could
actually be the one that leads to bigger
thing that eventually we can go back to
Iran more Tesa will start with you
I got 200 200 200 so go to Vegas bet on
the odds 200 so we're going to be in
Iran next year that's what you're saying
absolutely you think so you're that kind
of these people have nothing to lose
yeah I had a message for uh martial
artists
generally and men in Iran
when all we can do is all we can do I
cannot go back in the country I'm
prohibited to uh go by team but if I
could Patrick I wouldn't wait here one
minute
I told my daughter I told my son if
I could go you would you wouldn't see me
25 days ago I would be there wow because
I feel this is a time it's a
responsibility yeah
especially for my generation that
somehow we didn't do what we supposed to
do in our time and 79 happened we have
to pay our dues to the kids 12 14 years
old putting their life in their hands
and in the street they're getting bullet
and that so and so men or martial
artists sitting at home and waiting to
see you know smoke goes away and then
show up
it's ridiculous it's such a shame such a
shame we have to go in now otherwise
we're going to regret Patrick if this
regime stays after this event God
forbidden God forbid I don't want to
even think about it yeah nobody can
remove them anymore
we become worse than North Korea I think
it'll be bad my opinion I don't know if
it's permanent like you said 1400 275
you know the whole thing you were saying
earlier but here's what my worries are
with that is 400 billion dollars 25
years China is going to own Iran that's
the 400 billion dollar agreement 25
years so it's very upset about that too
yeah but but you know they took the
money it's kind of like so people were
upset I know well we're on the same page
and I know but that's my the reason why
you know how everybody's like this is
the election why you should vote for
Hillary if I should vote for Trump
because this is a different everybody
says the same script right but I believe
this is like the real one because you
don't want to be owned by China that's
my biggest concern because if we do
guess what next time I want to be able
to go fly in there and see my family 25
68 years from now 68 years from now it's
a long time from them I'd like to go on
the next 12 to 24 months and not have to
worry about my life when I go there so
I'm sorry God I'm going to get it how
long you guys think this is coming there
on 25 days and I wish them all the best
how long do you think this goes for how
long you think that you mean this
protesting this is going to last because
I mean it can't I'm not I mean it's
gonna stop but at some you I I don't
want it to I mean because they're going
to be in the streets until these people
are shooting and killing and you were
talking about it the youth it's the
young ones that are stepping they're
getting killed they're getting killed so
I just let me answer your display
there's a famous saying in Persian they
say when mullah get on the donkey
doesn't come down until the donkey dies
this thing is not gonna get over soon I
hope not they are gonna put so much
blood in the on the street and guess
what Freedom has it advice Freedom as a
price and if we don't pay the price
We're not gonna get it I agree well and
to wasn't your point or your point you
said we're not there that's what that's
the thing that's very upsetting is we
know what it takes for something to
change and it's a terrible feeling to
sit here and feel helpless and just
watch our countrymen get killed knowing
what they're fighting for knowing we all
we can do is amplify their voices there
was uh something that came out today one
of them Allah said um and he's known for
they're all hardliners but he's known
for just being a hardliner um his whole
career he said something like it was
translated as in whatever grievances you
all have
um I'm open to talking about it I saw
this briefly when I got off the plane so
that's a Show's a crack maybe a kraken
they're getting really they're showing
that they're worried like oh okay maybe
if we make some concessions but the
people have had it they're not trying
they're not in there for reform they're
for change regime change democracy
secularism no there's the the moment you
make concessions they're going to go
back to the same situation and this head
job issue is so it was one of the
pillars of the Islamic revolution so
they know the regime knows if these
women keep because you know there's all
these videos these girls are now women
are walking around Iran without their
head scarves and people are filming it
if they lose this issue they know that
it's only a matter of time until the
whole thing crumbles because that's the
one because then everyone's like okay
well now we're not wearing this okay
well now all my equal rights too my I
want my word to be a woman's word is
only worth 50 of a man's in court she
can't sing in public alone she can't
travel without permission of her husband
she can't get educated without the
permission of her husband if she wants
to get a divorce it's not up to her and
she loses custody immediately I'm all
there's a lot of things around it that
they're fighting for so they know once
the head job goes because that's the
biggest most obvious form of Oppression
everything else is going to crumble and
that's why I think they're starting to
we heard somebody say okay maybe we
should maybe we can talk about this guys
like they're like maybe we can talk
about this I hope they don't negotiate
no no one's I I hope they don't
negotiate it's past the nobody wants
reform and they're not saying reform
they're saying regime that's what
they're saying in the streets so pull it
um when you were talking about when you
when we talked about CNN and fox and
um what does it have to do with Iran it
has a lot to do with Iran because the
news media is not speaking the truth
everything they're talking about they're
like oh you know this person committed
suicide that person had heart and
condition so people are being fed that
that misinformation and they're learning
it from the best well CNN I said like I
said in the last week has been Jake
topper has been accurately reporting
information
um and if that's what you guys meant by
what does it have to do with Iran I
totally agree of course the media
coverage is not enough we still need
more everybody's I mean my friends none
of us are journalists by trade we're all
in the Arts or doctors lawyers every one
of the diaspora is like being the news
right now because the news isn't doing
their job
yeah I mean right now that's the I think
that's the great equalizer the great
equalizers were actually seeing it like
these clips you know how every time I
see these videos where it says uh uh you
know such and such content see why and
then hey you click to watch it there's
some it says something oh yeah uh
warning yeah some kind of a morning yeah
click on it and then you watch it you're
saying to yourself
this is this is not a movie this is real
someone's really going through this in
Iran right now and that's happening it's
getting suppressed on social media very
oddly too because and I think it's
people from the other side reporting
people's accounts uh
that if you even open some of the stuff
that says it's distressing it's actually
just like an article that uses the word
kill or death or murder I had a couple
posts up that I was literally just
translating what they were chanting in
the street and my account was reported
because it was like promoting violence
and and I and I wrote to meta and I know
someone that knows people at meta and
they got it taken care of which is you
guys have to understand Persian
translations to this wasn't me saying
let's go kill people I'm literally just
translating a slogan you know what I
mean yeah
those are unbelievable I do believe I
will give them benefit of the doubt that
they just
didn't have the mechanism in place and
now it's in place so yeah yeah so let's
give them benefit of the doubt and
hopefully that stuff you're back I never
got blocked that post got taken I got
you yeah and I think there needs to be
more famous bigger names that are going
to stand in the front and and help them
because I'm not really hearing anybody
there's a lot of celebrity well I love
Iranian or or I'm talking about like oh
like
somebody stood up and it was like Hey
listen look what's happening a lot more
eyes because I'm not gonna lie I'm not
seeing a lot of it I mean I'm seeing it
because
um you know my mom and dad from Iran and
I'm a Syrian but I want to see some big
I haven't heard any big names really
getting involved really in America I I
have Kim Kardashian Dua Lipa the Hadid
sisters um Ruby Rose Viola Davis I can
keep going but like I said yes well
that's what I'm saying where is it I
don't see it in the news because if like
if somebody that big to me posting it
yeah that's the problem I want to see
somebody really step up and really start
Kim Kardashian Kim Kardashian dedicated
her whole oh uh fashion houses did it a
few days ago Balenciaga Alexander
McQueen Gucci they all posted
we stand with the women of Iran so it's
happening good yeah this is great man
yep just telling you like if this thing
keeps you know momentum doesn't happen
overnight it takes a minute it's been
building yeah it's been building no no
question about it I mean again credit
goes to the people that are in Iran of
course I I just I just hope these people
that you know you know so one of the
things I was thinking about you know how
he said the show should have never left
if if you know how many was never in
Iran and he still was able to do the
revolution that it took place without
having to be in Iran right uh you know
like I'm trying to get a hold of a uh we
talked about him earlier Ali to speak to
him do you think it's safe for a guy
like that to stay there do you think
it's safe for him to stay there or it's
maybe not a bad idea for him to go to
home or school to Dubai which is only a
45 minute flight for who uh Ali Academy
or some of those not in Iran
okay he can't be in Iran right okay I
got you yeah not after what he said yeah
he would have I don't think he could
have said that inside there without
fearing for yeah there's there's uh some
guys like I'm glad he's not I thought he
was in Iran because we're trying to
message him and you know some people are
saying you're not going to get a hold of
him
it's good just the fact that there's
people like that that are talking it's
good and it's exciting that this
momentum's taking place and we
appreciate you guys coming out this was
a great conversation our audience is not
a big Iranian Community you know it's
like they're maybe less than one percent
of one percent Persian you know the
podcast is different content which is
even better because people who don't
really follow this story now gotta you
know a good clinic on what's really
taking place from different perspectives
Banner we're keeping it on the bridge
when traffic comes
thousands of cars that are honking that
we're looking at them from the up
they're like white yeah they're like
black they're they're not Persian and
they see Spanish they're like it's
becoming very popular in this thing be
getting people's attention yes
somebody said they're they're trying to
do an event that you YouTube arena with
six seven thousand people where they're
bringing the you know Darius and people
like that in L.A yeah there's something
being planned is there I want to go to
it I'll tell you what okay okay no the
only reason I'm saying this is I'm open
to the idea of renting out Staples on a
one day full event I say you're missing
live all day listen if any of these guys
would have any interest and they're
close to any domain like I'm thinking
like 12 hours straight concert
performing talking bring the youngest
rappers from Darius to Google to every
one of them and do a one day full we
rent out the Staples Center and put on a
nice AV team and 100 of money that comes
and goes to whatever charity we can
trust or form of helping you know where
you know we're able to do something with
that and uh people can keep giving we'll
create a 1-800 number and show live
exactly how much money we're raising you
know that's not going to be hard in the
next seven to 14 days in the next week
or two I'll tell you about that offline
but also there's a group of people that
I know too it's a large Collective I
don't know everybody in it it's Iranians
based mostly out of Los Angeles I think
um that have started this GoFundMe and
they're raising funds to buy ad space
and billboards uh in media different
media markets so that they can get the
word out because it's not being reported
on so that's also happening too I like
that other angle I like us like if
there's a if we know where the money
goes to yeah too many times you're given
money like to places where it's like the
money doesn't do like the whole 900 000
black lives you want the money to go to
a place that you know what they're going
to be doing with it big pieces
that is the one okay there you go put
that link below add ad space and media
space okay sounds good well folks
hopefully uh you know if you didn't have
any plans about learning more about Iran
you just did because we had five people
that are Iranian here and we we were
equal opportunities
Tyler honestly your commentary tonight
was the best
your commentary a little long to get
that data for me
you're talking to the best in the
business here I think you were I think
you're doing it on purpose but that's
like we're up in rock he's trying to be
friendly to you he's trying to be nice
he wants you to live with a good
experience if you're upset he's like I
love Tucker Carlson yes my uncle
anyways
that was like that's his last name is
Tyler Carlson oh snap she becomes the
director of that HBO documentary and
you're related to Taco girls yeah great
okay uh having said that thank you for
coming out thank you for having me thank
you thank you everybody for coming out
this was fantastic folks it was nice to
meet you have a great day are we doing
podcasts tomorrow morning we got
podcasts tomorrow yeah we're doing
podcast tomorrow morning home team we're
just talking Uh current events okay
fantastic have a good one everybody take
care bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye thank you
dude thank you